a weird company has been working in
elections around the world for a long
time and allegedly worked on the brexit
campaign and the Trump presidential
campaigns as well as others for people
who are hoping for a movie that gives
you the proof of whether or not the
stuff worked those people will be
disappointed this is not a movie about
whether it worked this is a movie about
whether we can live in a democracy where
this stuff is going on we really can't
know whether any of this was the
defining factor in any of these
elections there's no control group in
elections you cannot determine whether
or not this affected that it's all of
the above when people think about why
did people vote for breakfast it and why
did people vote for Trump there's no
single reason there is a perfect storm
of reasons I think one of most alarming
things about this company and this movie
is that fundamental idea that Americans
are working on British politics and
Brits are working on American politics
we should just be working in our own
politics and that's it to be honest the
popularity of this movie will inspire
more bad guys to do more bad things so
it shows us that we need to inoculate
ourselves against this and we need to
make sure that our governments are ready
to try and withstand these kinds of
attempts to subvert and industrialize
democracy itself
I'm joined by Professor David Carroll
professor welcome the show it's great to
be on here thanks for having me what is
your life like at the moment it's pretty
overwhelming
the response to the film is mind-blowing
mostly because I get so many messages
per minute from people around the world
saying that their mind is blown so this
sort of mutual mind blowing is happening
right now
and it's overwhelming III never expected
it to go this big so I mean you were in
the press the during the first iteration
like the the real-time unveiling of this
particular storyline and now there's
this sort of recap of all of that that's
got Netflix's power behind it
so yeah it's a it doesn't surprise me
that you're feeling a little bit
overwhelmed by that the last couple of
days it's only been out for upon when
we're recording now like two days I
think twenty-fourth it came out on
Netflix and usually when people suggest
something to me and different spheres of
awareness say the same thing and that
right I need to I need to take notice of
this in the space of two days I'd like
five people at my own mind if you watch
that the great hack on Netflix it's sick
you gotta go watch it okay cool fair
enough
so yes for the people who do not know
why your life is chaos at the moment and
and what's been going on could you give
us a rundown of what we're talking about
sure
so a weird company has been working in
elections around the world for a long
time and allegedly worked on the brexit
campaign and the Trump presidential
campaigns as well as others and the
movie looks at the stories of three
people who were involved in learning
more and unraveling the scandal behind
that so it follows Carole Cadwallader
who was the primary journalist for The
Observer and the Guardian who really
uncovered the story for the press and
the world it
Britany Kaiser who was really high up in
the company and was with the company up
until the very end and she tries to come
out and you know spill the information
that everybody is seeking and then
myself who learned that I could try to
get my data from the company using
British law and it follows my legal
struggle still to this day trying to get
my data back which under British law is
required and so it's been fascinating to
see how the British government being
Parliament and the Information
Commissioner have been the strongest
force in the world to hold the company
accountable in even more accountable
than the United States government in the
United States regulators so the movie is
a story about how journalism and
citizens and the law can hack back
against these technological forces for
people who are hoping for a movie that
explains and gives you the proof of
whether or not the stuff worked those
people will be disappointed this is not
a movie about whether it worked this is
a movie about whether we can live in a
democracy where this stuff is going on
yeah the big question that hangs over
the top of all of it is did they do it
right like if you watch the movie at the
end of it there's still the natural
slipperiness of large corporations like
this and the specific evasive tactics
that get used in hearings and stuff like
that there's no straight answer there
isn't a yes we did it no we didn't and
for every accusation so there's an
accusation they worked with levy you
this is Cambridge analytic is that
company that we're talking about there's
an accusation they worked with leave da
EU and it there's some pretty damning
evidence like emails going backwards and
forwards Brittany who was one of the
head exact they're sitting on the
announcement for the levy you think etc
etc and yet when asked Andrew Nicks who
is the head guy at camera generally
because says no we didn't do it it was
Andrew Nicks Alexander Alexander next
sorry yeah
yes and he says no we didn't so even
that is like no straight answers does it
feel a little bit like trying to play
whack-a-mole with this well it's really
interesting it's been a story about
finding the truth and realizing the
fragility of truth in this age and the
reality that this story has intrinsic
ambiguity because we really can't know
whether any of this was the defining
factor in any of these elections there's
no control group in elections you cannot
determine whether or not this effect of
that it's a it's a it's all of the above
when people think about why did people
vote for brexit and why did people vote
for Trump there's no single reason there
is a perfect storm of reasons and so
this is one of the reasons but what it
really shows us is who is determining
truth now and I really saw truth out of
the only place I knew that it could be
reliable in this age and that is in the
courts legal truth is now the only pure
truth because the Machine the media
machine is a truth distortion device and
then social media is a truth distortion
device so when we had people lying to
reporters and we have people even lying
to lawmakers the best way than to find
the truth would be in the courts and in
forensic documents and basically what is
on the servers and so luckily the UK
information Commissioner seized the
servers under criminal warrant an
important fact that the film depicts an
important fact that many people do not
realize and has been conducting an
incredible forensic investigation on the
servers and so they say in the autumn
there will be a public report on what is
on those servers and to me that will be
the most reliable most definitive set of
evidence to
answer the question who was Cambridge
analytic a what did they have how did
they use it and could it have had an
effect we could we shouldn't even try to
make those assessments until we have
hard forensic evidence of what they had
if it turns out that their data was none
and nothing special let's look at the
data and decide that if it turns out
that they really did have this
extraordinary database let's see what
was in there
and see what could happen at the minimum
we know what's out there so that we can
think about the future the next
elections that are coming up right away
this technology is only going to expand
and has capabilities and to be honest
that the popularity of this movie will
inspire more bad guys to do more bad
things so it shows us that we need to
inoculate ourselves against this and we
need to make sure that our governments
are ready to try and withstand these
kinds of attempts to subvert and
industrialize democracy itself is that
the scene where the police or the law
enforcement go into the office building
and then pull the blinds down and you
can kind of see through yeah for anyone
who was watching that was I wouldn't it
what the comeuppance of that was right
because Cambridge analytic have filed
for bankruptcy went into administration
quite early in the Proceedings of when
they realized that there was some [ __ ]
incoming for one of a better term and I
wondered how much of that stuff were
they able to get rid of sure everyone
will be thinking well what did they wipe
like if the law enforcement find X then
what didn't they find what had already
perhaps managed to be binned etc etc so
could you just give the listeners a
background to Cambridge analytical sort
of where they'd been before the the two
main situations that we come up against
which is brexit and Trump's campaign in
2016
sure so the parent company or the main
company which is called SEL it stands
for used to stand for strategic
Communications Laboratories it's
actually a company that's I think about
20 years old it's been around for a
while actually and when you dig into the
history of the company they've been
working in what they call election
management and also defense contracting
for quite some time now and ultimately
when I first got into this story it
actually was the military work that
disturbed me and troubled me the most
this idea that a defense contractor was
now getting into the business of
elections and the boundary between the
military-industrial complex and free and
fair elections had been breached by the
fact that the company started a
elections division called Cambridge
analytic especially to get involved in
elections in the United States and to
provide services to the Republican Party
and in many ways in response to the
success of the Barack Obama campaign the
sort of arms race that political parties
are engaged in and in one-upping each
other to win elections using the latest
technologies so I think the film does a
good job of acknowledging that reality
and that with each successive election
we gets more and more insane so what are
we gonna do to slow down the pace of
escalation there's sort of a mutually
assured destruction undertone to this
that if we continue to allow military
contractors to internationalize and
industrialize de ma commercialize and
commercialize it to the highest bidder
and that there really are British
aristocrats thinking they can like
reconstruct the British Empire through
companies like this it's a kind of new
colonialism and as an American one of
the first sort of alarming things that I
felt when I discovered who this
what this really was and found some
forensic proof that confirmed my worst
fears is I really did have the feeling
of like why is the British company
interfering in my election it wasn't
about the Russians it was about the
British any 200 years so it's like there
shouldn't be any election of
interference the election should be
domestic affairs and I think one of most
alarming things about this company and
this movie is that fundamental idea that
Americans are working on British
politics and Brits are working on
American politics we should just be
working at our own politics and that's
it yeah there was some pretty harrowing
examples of the stuff the SCL in their
military form had managed to achieve
prior to this right so they've done some
stuff in Trinidad and Tobago where
they'd come up with a campaign which
essentially was targeted at young voters
but they knew that encouraging young
voters not to vote was going to
asymmetrically affect a particular
demographic that demographic was the one
that they didn't want to vote and it was
the Indian and African on the other side
yeah it's in the film points out that
every country and every electorate has a
unique cultural political condition and
in Trinidad and Tobago you have this
sort of racial and ethnic divide between
the the people who migrated from India
and the people who were brought there by
the slave trade so the afro-caribbeans
and so and then those divisions that are
built into society can be exploited and
fermented to manipulate democracies and
the film does a chilling job of showing
how the sort of military mindset of
going into population and analyzing it
for its weaknesses can be used against
it it doesn't necessarily even need big
data to do so and I think the film does
a good job of showing how this
a company that's been around for a while
and has been developing these tactics
and then what has sort of escalated it
is that they have adopted big data
analytics to further yeah will weaponize
these tactics above what they already
were yeah so I think that is what is
alarming now there it's not in the movie
but there are research and reports that
somehow SCL got its hands on the data
from the Trinidadian ISP and so did use
some data harvesting to try to develop
models of the electorate and so what's
interesting too is this movie just sort
of gives you enough to understand and
become alarmed but there's so many
threads that the viewer could take from
the movie and then do their own
investigations and dive deeper and find
that the movie is just scratching the
surface in a lot of ways yeah it is the
hub in the center of a spoke of rabbit
holes that you can tumble down on the
internet which is the reason why I only
got about five hours of sleep last night
after I finished watching it so thanks
for that food yeah so yeah coming back
to the SEL thing which I think is
important for people that are listening
even the ones that have watched the
documentary to kind of frame what we're
talking about here the fact that they
were able to enact social change without
big data so big data was allowing them
to target more effectively but their
understanding of behavioral economics
and behavior change generally allowed
them to distribute a message at social
campaign across all of Trinidad and
Tobago
and downstream from that not even like
the first or second order effect like
the fifth sixth order effect was the one
that they wanted and it was going to
discriminate and it caused enough of a
swing in voter turnout to effect the
election in the direction that allegedly
their particular employer or the person
who commissioned that work wanted and
then they've
push this forward and then created the
knot well I don't to say non militarized
version but like the commercial aspect
of that which is what became Cambridge
analytical and you've got this really
sort of shady Bond type villain guy
Alexander nicks who's the guy that's
behind it all
it would appear and the whole the whole
company when you start to learn about
Kaman generally Korean particularly
about Alexander himself just immediately
makes me think about a Dan Brown novel
you know one of the like evil geniuses
from a Dan Brown novel that's in that
sort of place and it's really it's very
harrowing like as you're watching it
incredibly harrowing yeah and there are
characters in the company which are who
are not in the film or are sort of
secondary characters so you know
Alexander Nicks seems to be the real
salesman behind the operation but there
are other figures in the company that
are not in the movie a key character
who's not mentioned once is a person
named Nigel Oakes and he is reported to
be more of the brains behind the
operation the expert in behavioral
dynamics he calls it which is what you
were describing like economic psychology
at behavioral economics and it really
comes from the advertising world he used
to be a Saatchi and Saatchi and really
did you know pursue a path of taking the
principles of how advertising and
marketing works and applying those to
political warfare and has done work for
governments in winning hearts and minds
especially after 9/11 so after September
11th the focus of especially the US
military but all many allies sort of
started to work on how you could counter
violent extremism without escalating
more violence
so using these kinds of techniques were
deployed and Nigel Oaks is really the
hidden figure behind that work and he's
still in operation there is one company
that did not go bankrupt or insolvent
it's called SEL insights limited and
it's the last surviving SCL company and
according to my lawsuit I discovered
that he acquired the assets of SEL group
and move them into SEL insights and so
that is a continuing concern and I also
was able to determine that just days
before the scandal exploded last spring
so sort of the weekend of March 16 17 18
when the whole thing exploded that that
week
SEL group led by Nigel Oaks had given a
presentation to the State Department in
the United States about countering
violent extremism with their techniques
and that was from a contract that SEL
group earned during the Trump transition
and there's public documents that show
that Mike Flynn who it was a character
in the mother investigation and who was
caught while lying to the FBI and was
fired from the Obama campaign and fired
from the Trump campaign and he had a
pretty previously undisclosed consulting
gig with SEL group and the timeline
overlaps in a stunning way where he had
a consulting gig with SEL in November
and December of 2016 during the
transition and then there are also
public documents revealed where the
company was given its contract to the
State Department and then right before
the whole thing explodes we we see that
that you know they were actually
delivering their work on countering
violent extremism and one of the
interesting things when you sort of
become well-known
for this stuff is anonymous people start
sending you things so I was sent the
presentation deck that Nigel Oakes
presented to the State Department that
day and it was a fascinating look into
what s Ciel's work for governments looks
like hmm and how the same techniques as
they would claim be used for good and
arguably yes like if you can convince
young Muslims to not join Isis that is a
good thing no no one can dispute that is
what we want so an interesting like so
the data point that I found interesting
from that presentation was SDL's
methodology had shown that the primary
motivator for young men in the Islamic
world is actually not religious ideology
it is economics that most young
disaffected men join these kinds of
terror groups because of the lack of
Economic Opportunity there's more
opportunity to get paid if you become a
terrorist unfortunately in many of these
failed societies and then the tactics
that they're recommending are related to
this observation that what you know get
that observation from do you know how
they got that that's really there on the
ground Survey Research they're
old-fashioned
kind of market research so not really
the big data analytics what I we were
talking about before the sort of good
old-fashioned on-the-ground panel
research interviews they send out like
crews to do interviews they do surveys
they do individual interviews sort of
good old-fashioned qualitative research
and that actually initially informs some
of their tactics and methods and then
that tends to be sort of further
augmented by big data analytics to sort
of further validate the initial
assumptions that might be developed in a
qualitative sense but just to me it was
so disturbing
and so fascinating that essentially the
same company that was telling the State
Department that the reason there is Isis
is because of the failures of capitalism
and that same company was you know
telling the president that the way that
he could win the election was by
fomenting the divisions in American
society and fomenting Islamophobia and
fomenting a fear of the other in order
to win it was just chilling to realize
that the same company was advising both
things
yeah and it's astonishing to comprehend
that yeah it really is I think one thing
that comes to mind is as technology
progresses the same way as a wheel could
have been made to make a cart which
allows someone a farmer in a field to
pull their hay around more easily that
same wheel can also be fitted to the
bottom of a tank to make a war machine
as technology begins to develop and
improve and is easier for people to get
hold of these situations the the line
between good and evil actually becomes
more magnified and the implications
become greater and that's why stuff like
this I think is so chilling that people
can see also another thing is that it's
at the mercy of whims of humans right
like these Cambridge analytic or SEL or
whatever could in some different
iteration of the universe have been
totally righteous and super virtuous and
been like right we're gonna help
humanitarian causes and we're gonna have
enact change so that people donate the
right amounts or so that people improve
their recycling so that people you know
companies understand that climate
changes of it etcetera etcetera etc and
they have this power and the direction
in which they choose to swing it is
totally down to them until they're
litigated into a box and once it's out
of a different box once it's been open
that doors been
this technology exists it's not going
back in like it's not going anywhere so
one of the first things I think that a
lot of people will be thinking one the
biggest questions I've had so far which
I want to ask yourself is what do we do
about companies that hold this sort of
power you have them across nation states
you have them outside of the
jurisdiction of one particular
government what have you got any idea
about how we begin to tackle this
problem yes I definitely would agree
that you know that people say the genie
is out of the bottle we can't go back to
the innocent world that we thought we
had it's true and like I said before
some critics of this movie could say
that you know you've done a terrific
advertising campaign for these kinds of
bad actors you've glorified them and
their magical abilities but I have felt
that it was worth creating the awareness
of what is underneath these structures
and it was worth being able to tell the
story of how individual action can
interface with government accountability
and so it's a real stress test for our
institutions which are being tested to
the limit in terms of can they as its
said in the movie as its as the the
final report from Parliament suggests
that the are our institutions and
regulations fit for purpose they were
designed to do something and this whole
scandal is the ultimate stress test of
all these institutions across different
countries we have we've had a
transnational investigation that is
involved at at times the United States
the United Kingdom and Canada the film
to keep it simple has actually not
included some very important strands of
the scandal
ah sure there's a variable to tell us
about some of those sure sure so there's
a whole part of the scandal that
involves a Canadian company called
aggregate IQ which the film does not
mention when you get deep into the
rabbit hole you realize it's a huge part
of the story
it's where Chris Wylie came from and
aggregate IQ is central to a lot of the
scandal related to brexit and the
illegal coordination and illegal
spending part of the brexit scandal and
that side of the story is much
interestingly much more connected to
Boris Johnson's sort of wing of the
conservative side whereas the great hack
focuses more on the Aaron banks Nigel
Faraj side of the the British political
establishment and so that whole part of
the scandal got cut off and chunked up
because it would get a complicated story
even more unwieldy but interestingly I
think the the BBC HBO fictionalization
of brexit that starred Benedict
Cumberbatch that actually is dramatizing
that side of the scandal so I actually
think the filmmakers felt justified in
like leaving that whole thing aside
because it has been dramatized already
oh yeah there's no need to read to do
that but for viewers trying to put the
pieces together if you've seen the
brexit movie that's the side of the
story that the great hack didn't bother
touching instead it focused on the more
Faraj and Trump and Bannen side of the
scandal so but back to the question of
like what can we do about it or what's
possible clearly the need for
international cooperation has been
demonstrated that lawmakers have to
collaborate as allies to hold bad actors
and rogue operations accountable as well
as legitimate massive
multinational corporations like Facebook
and Google that they're both it's both a
responsibility of sort of international
cooperation because no one government or
state can handle it by themselves that
indeed it took the UK digital media
culture and Sport Committee to take a
really aggressive stance on getting to
the dancers and those lawmakers did not
take a deferential stance to anyone not
SEL Cambridge analytical not Facebook
they were aggressive because they knew
they had to be whereas by comparison US
lawmakers in Congress and Senate
exhibited tremendous deference to
Facebook because it is domestic company
there was a fear of hurting an American
business when we when you go back in
like you know listen to those
testimonies a lot of times the lawmakers
would especially on the Republican side
but even on the detect the Democratic
side would just like start out with
Facebook is the an America is amazing
business it's the greatest you know part
of it yeah yeah yes yes they start out
flattering him and then maybe sort of
sneak a good question or a critique and
whereas the UK lawmakers just were
aggressive so so you know even they
don't give a [ __ ] that's that's that's
oh sure no no and we needed that we
needed lawmakers with power to be
aggressive and the the parliamentarians
in uh in Ottawa we're also really agar
aggressive were also took a firm stand
and so to me it shows that and then of
course there was also this grand
committee that was formed which include
11 Parliament's from around the world
and Zuckerberg refused to appear before
any of them
so there was defiance by characters like
Alexander Knicks who were willing to lie
to these guys the that the heads of
aggregate IQ were completely defiant to
verga government so the guys who got
caught in Canada when you can you can go
back and watch those hearings and just
like it's insane to see these guys just
Stonewall their own government and and
then the way that you know Mark
Zuckerberg didn't even have the balls to
appear before Parliament's in the UK in
uh in Canada and even this grand
assembly so because Facebook is a super
state it requires international
cooperation to stand up to to them no
one country alone is gonna do it
question of HUD's on the tip of my
tongue throughout all of this
how culpable is Facebook in this and
where does their culpability lie because
they are not Cambridge on Latika they
are somehow the conduit / communications
medium how does Facebook fit into all of
this sort of stuff I wasn't able to
attend the screening in the panel in
Washington DC this week but Shoshanna
Zubov was on a panel in the one that was
a screened on Capitol Hill she's the
author of the age of surveillance
capitalism the sort of definitive truth
treatise on this larger issue she was
highly influential in the filmmakers
vision of this Roger Magnum a is a
proponent of her as well and she made
the comment that basically and I think
this is this is it his Facebook was the
host and Cambridge analytical was the
parasite that that that's that that's
the story here is that that there that
the Facebook is the has tremendous
culpability in creating this machine
that had no mechanisms for security that
it was just used
it was meant to be used it was used to
sell you know it was built to sell skin
cream and ski vacations and was
deliberately designed to also then sell
candidates and allow candidates to find
voters and it was deliberately designed
and sold to to sell election outcomes
and campaigns were info like like the
the movie does a good job of reminding
people that Facebook put its own
employees directly embedded into the
Trump campaign and the movie does a good
job of then hinting that Facebook had to
have been aware that they were working
side by side with Cambridge analytic are
embedded in the Trump campaign in 2016
despite the fact that that the company
had identified Cambridge analytic as a
rogue operator that had violated their
policies that had required them to
certify the deletion of illicit data and
so that Facebook knew that Cambridge
analytic ah were it was a sketchy
operation why do you think they allowed
them to continue is someone getting a
backhander somewhere is there pressure
from litigation or someone that has some
power what why are they allowing
Cambridge analytic it to continue that's
the key question
what do you think I mean there are so
many parts of the story that looked like
a cover-up to us weird things that
Facebook did that make us lose trust in
them well when you dig when you dig into
the story so when you realize that the
the two academics from Cambridge
University that created the company that
actually did the data harvesting were
Alexandra Kogut
and this and and Alexander Kogan's
postdoc researcher an American named
Joseph Chancellor and they formed the
company together and even though Cogan
was the the lead he had a partner and
when Facebook discovered that the the
data was being sold which was ill which
was against their own policies they
strangely ended up hiring just a
chancellor right into Facebook so
basically a guy who was caught selling
data basically took to using academic
research as a as a way to obscure the
commercialization of it to be used for
political purposes you know that is a
very you know that's like against
Facebook's own policies it's also
illegal in the United Kingdom and they
hired him and he worked there for awhile
and it was only when people started
asking Facebook meaning US senators on
both sides of the aisle who is Joseph
Chancellor tell us about him what is
going on with him why basically asking
like why did you hire this guy and they
said they're who conduct an internal
investigation they said they completed
their investigation and then he was
dismissed without any explanation and so
he doesn't work for Facebook anymore
he's never been interviewed he's never
made a public statement nobody knows
anything about him and it's just
mysterious there's too many like
unexplained things for us to just keep
going on and you know every every
everything is fine the other mulling on
all of the different threads yeah yeah
the other important part of this that in
in it sort of shows signs of a cover-up
is the Attorney General in Washington DC
Carl
Racine has filed a lawsuit against
Facebook for Cambridge analytic because
it violated consumer protection laws in
the District of Columbia and it's one of
the most it's one of the lawsuits in the
u.s. that I'm following the closest and
he has really after the release of the
movie he actually refiled his demand to
have internal emails unsealed and
because he's in the discovery of that
lawsuit he's gotten even emails that
show Facebook employees in Washington DC
knew about Cambridge analytic a way
earlier than has been publicly disclosed
and there are specific emails that are
redacted that you can see and it's like
them talking about Cambridge analytic
and Facebook is desperate not to have
these emails unsealed because it will
show what they knew about this company
when they knew about it and who knew
about it and the who what when is still
unanswered and Zuckerberg asserted to
Congress under oath that he learned
about Cambridge analytic from the first
Guardian article in December 2015 which
is incredulous and even if that's true
then it means that there is a management
crisis at this company that you could
find a military contractor harvesting
data on your platform and you do not
escalate it to the c-level suite like if
that's the internal story then that is a
damning story of mismanagement or or
Zuckerberg committed perjury that's like
that's the only explanation that I can
understand from from knowing the details
here and that I think is why Facebook is
desperate to keep those emails sealed
because as soon as you get a verifiable
email of basically what I what I worry
about is a Washington DC employee said I
did some googling on this weird company
yeah they're a defense contractor
they're scraping data what do we do
about it what you reckon the low-level
anxiety rating is in Facebook at the
moment like it's just gonna be
everyone's just going to be walking
around with terror hanging over their
heads at the moment that something's
going to come out because I don't see
how this ends well for them as you've
said there's two two options one is that
they are malicious in their purposeful
deception and the second is that they're
incompetent in the naivety I think it's
both yeah that they achieved so much
power so quickly hmm and did not
understand the power that they wielded
and they did not have the moral culture
to understand their power as it was
being abused at scale and by multiple
ways so well we can tell that there's
been like a kind of rent reckoning but
at the same time the business model is
inherently immoral and it is not there's
no the business model is asymmetric in
its power and it's it's ultimately about
dispossession and the movie does a good
job of of expressing that our said that
the the the the bargain the grand
bargain of social media is completely
asymmetric and as dispossessing us of
not only ourselves and our free will but
it has a collective harm to our all
societies and that the whole deal has to
be renegotiated the in order for us to
yep the implications are really really
broad on they one of the things that
I've been thinking I wonder whether you
thought this yourself as
you know that some of the listeners will
have done as I was watching the movie I
was thinking to myself well yeah but you
know those like some people some voters
might have got taken in by this
particular disinformation or the memes
or whatever the campaigns that were put
forward but like you know I'm I'm
probably a bit self-aware or maybe I'm
not online as much as them or whatever
it is
I found myself coming up with my own
excuses for why I wasn't affected I
wonder I wonder how common that is that
we we believe were so aware of our own
biases but looking at some of the stats
that was cited at the end is it like
60,000 Facebook ads were online for
Hillary and 1.1 million were online for
Trump is that a roundabout right yeah I
mean I think it's a shame that there
hasn't been interest in doing the
post-mortem on the Hillary digital
campaign they're dirt they're different
kind of skeletons in the Hillary digital
campaign closet and there's only been a
few scant accounts of what went on there
but I think it's an equally interesting
story that I hope somebody tells someday
soon because it's a different parable on
the other side of the story so as I
understand it Eric Schmidt of Google was
very active in directly supporting the
Hillary do digital operation and they
had a AI brain essentially that they
called Ava named
after Ava Ella Lovelace who is the you
know really important female programmer
in the history of programming she
recently invented the algorithm and it
was basically like Alexa or Siri for
digital campaigning they would literally
like ask Ava where should we run ads
tomorrow and where should Hillary go
campaigning tomorrow and Ava would
crunch the numbers and give them the
answers and my hypothesis is that they
were so enchanted with
it's this basically immature AI the
shiny object of asking Ava for the magic
answers and they believed this robot way
too much and by sort of my worst case
scenario sort of imagination is that
they asked a Ava where should Hillary go
and a and Ava never said go to Wisconsin
so they never went to Wisconsin and
Hillary needed to have campaigned really
hard in Wisconsin so you think answered
Sylvania and identify if or why there
was some glaring omissions in a campaign
tour could be we don't have enough
information to know but that's what I
worry about that then that the the sort
of unforced errors of the digital
strategy were informed by something or
someone hmm who who made those sort of
core strategic errors how is the data
abused to make mistakes and how was the
faith in technology overblown how is
this like arms race to be better than
the opponents opposing side how did that
bite the Democrats in the ass in the end
they were like using technology that was
not ready for primetime
that was that was you know version point
one instead okay now analytical version
4.0 yeah exactly and that good
old-fashioned direct marketing
techniques actually won the day and I
think that that's Brad Parr scales core
competency is just sort of old-fashioned
direct marketing techniques on steroids
and when you give that guy a huge budget
he gets Trump voters by getting
donations and selling merchandise and
getting people to go to rallies it is
just old-fashioned Direct Marketing and
I don't think we should underestimate
the power of people you know investing
in a candidate with their own money
buying
merchandise and branding themselves with
the campaign and going to these rallies
which are the closest thing you're ever
gonna see the fascist rallies in the
United States and you know being a part
of this highly charged very terrifying
on the ground movement there's a
question hanging over everyone's heads
even those of us in the UK who watched
with kind of like watching a sitcom a
terrifying sitcom unfold when the
Hillary and Trump election night went on
interesting but not our problem kind of
there's a question hanging over
everyone's heads I think still to this
day even when I hear people talk about
it how did this happen
or now it's how did that happen I
suppose and this recent exposure that's
coming out of the great hack adds
another not excuse but another reason
another layer to that that there's all
of these questions there's a molar
report there's the the Cambridge
analytical scandal there's Facebook
there's all of these sort of different
elements and people do you think people
are starting to get a grasp of how did
this happen because everyone's been post
hoc rationalization
try to start to play the identity
politics game and delet they'd started
to subsist to the left to far-left etc
etc all that's written post hoc
rationalization because no one saw
except for like Scott Adams on Twitter
no one saw it in advance sure and now
there's more elements of this coming out
do you think people are starting to get
more of a grasp or is it just the first
in a number of unveilings to come I hope
people stop looking for single reasons
for things and start to understand it's
a it's a complex network of factors that
interconnect and interrelate and amplify
each other so sort of as time has passed
we're able to actually have a more
sophisticated understanding I like the
way the film also points to things that
happened a long time ago that
contributed toward this outcome the sort
of
butterfly effect that things happen and
then the resulting effects echo down the
road so the way that the mortgage crisis
in 2008 still reverberates to the day
this day the Great Recession that will
wipe the wealth out of so many Americans
what's not mentioned in the film which I
think is another significant social
issue in the United States is the
opiates crisis and the greed of the
pharmaceutical industry and the kind of
crazy reverse racism that occurred there
so basically this hypothesis that the
pharmaceutical industry like over
marketed opiates and doctors over
prescribed to working white patients and
actually would not prescribe to African
American patients and so the white
population United States is now like in
this addiction plague and we're just
realizing it and has destroyed families
destroyed communities especially in
these white working-class states so feel
how you had the great recession caused
by the greed of Wall Street you had this
opiates crisis caused by the greed of
pharmaceuticals now you have this like
crisis and democracy called caused by
the greed of Silicon Valley and the
surveillance capitalists so it's like a
reckoning of years actually in the
making of sort of the self-destructive
pensions of American culture growth at
all costs greed is good kind of way of
being and then we haven't even mentioned
Fox News which traces back to Ronald
Reagan when he got rid of the what was
called the fairness of the doctrine
where the FCC that rate we regulated
broadcast used to be a said a doctrine
it you have to give both sides to the
issue if you use the public airwaves and
Reagan got rid of that and that created
the opportunity to create part
in news outlets as well radio is that
only in the States because the UK
doesn't seem to have that same split
yeah that could it be say it up until
the a the a a DS broadcast news
broadcast news in the US was very
balanced because of the Fairness
Doctrine this idea of the government
owned the airwaves the spectrum news
companies leased the airwaves from the
government a public good and in in order
for them to do that they had to have a
fair use of the airwaves Reagan got rid
of that let people do whatever they want
with the public airwaves it created the
potential to then split news into
political viewpoints so this like
dividing the you know sort of dividing
the nation rather than keeping it
unified through technology and
government policy and media is something
that started in the 80s 30 years in them
and that yeah and and then it just built
and built a built and then in the early
2000s the internet came and radically
changed the whole media and business
ecology of the world but especially how
news and media and advertising worked so
that contributed towards the
acceleration of these trends not only
into like hyper-partisan news outlets
but individualized hyper-partisan news
feeds and and then the way that our
personal data was collected without
rights without restriction wild west of
surveillance capitalism to create this
business incentive to trap people into
filter bubbles to use fear and anxiety
to boost engagement to the maximum
levels we built the machine
that tore us apart because it made the
charts go up and that's all people were
looking at their their engagement charts
their financial return charts saving
money on their ad chart the whole
industry and society was just looking at
these charts and we're not looking out
the window at what was happening on on
the streets yeah we were asleep at the
wheel the businessman got more profits
and the users got some good cat memes
every so often and everyone was happy
and the world continued on until until
this happened one question I can't
remember whether you mention it in the
documentary or not
why did you file in the UK what's
specific about UK law yeah so this is a
subtle takeaway that I hope a lot of
people realize is I had no US lawyers I
had no rights or recourse in my own
country I only had rights in the United
Kingdom and the reason for that is us
voter data was processed in the United
Kingdom so therefore you get rights
where your data is processed
if the Cambridge analytic I had kept
American voter data in the United States
and not exported it abroad then I would
have had no rights or recourse at all
I could have requested the company and
they could have ignored me and there
would be no legal basis to challenge
that because they were based in the UK
they were forced to respond to my
request and then the Information
Commissioner and Parliament had
jurisdiction to further support and
advance my complaint and so it is an
incredible parable of what you could
start to call the Splinter net where is
the internet works differently depending
on where you are in the world and right
now if you're in the EU and they you're
a resident of even the Member States you
are protected by the GDP are in
Internet whereas we don't have the
equivalent of the GDP are in the United
States so we don't have the basic rights
that the GDP our enables and one of the
fascinating things that I learned about
all this is because the EU is a
relatively new institution they have
data protection rights enshrined in the
Charter so you rights to your data is
fundamental right to freedom of speech
and freedom to get married and like all
these things it's fundamental because it
was thought of in a world where with
where we like knew this the law that I
was able to use is called the UK Data
Protection Act of 1998 so astonishingly
the British Parliament passed a law at
the dawn of the Internet in 1998 was
first being commercialized and they had
the wherewithal to predict that people
would need basic data rights we never
did this in the United States so there
is nothing in the Constitution that
guarantees your access to your day data
so whereas it is in law across the
Atlantic and so that's the lesson to
Americans is there's a very specific
right that we have to demand now it is
the right to our own data and it has to
be fundamental it has to maybe even be
in the Constitution like the right to
bear arms the right to freedom of speech
the right to your data is so fundamental
in the 21st century and this movie shows
us why that matters and I hope people
take that away and I hope that they then
when they are trying to what do I do now
it is actually go to your lawmakers at
the state and federal level and say we
need data rights we need the at least
the equivalent rights of our friends in
Europe and the UK that's a really really
interesting next step the Splinter net
is something that I hadn't thought of
but you are totally right I have a
couple of more questions that have been
sent through to me the first one being
that no matter how much traction
this documentary gets and I'm certain
it's going to get a lot lawmakers are
gonna take time catching up you guys
have a fairly important election coming
pretty soon what do you think we can
expect over the next year so the first I
hope is a realization that nothing has
changed we are not any more protected
than we were in 2016 so the government
did not act fast enough to protect us
even though it's all we've been talking
about so the best we have is an
awakening a new awareness that we were
asleep and 2016 and at least now we are
awake but we should expect the same
actors to do the same things they did
before and even more sophisticated so we
just have to be even more vigilant and
try to inoculate ourselves and then not
give up on what we need to do and to try
to make this part of the campaign you
know it's an opportunity to pressure the
politicians to confront this because one
of the paradoxes here is on both sides
of the aisle
especially United States there really
don't want to kneecap Facebook too much
because they realize they need Facebook
to stay in power they need Facebook to
motivate their voters and to target them
and so you're asking them to limit their
own ability to stay in power so we need
to confront the extra challenge of
asking our lawmakers to give us rights
and reduce their ability to manipulate
us to keep them in power and that's huge
and really difficult so we need to deal
with that and it's particularly
interesting dynamic in the United States
is the idea that there are laws passed
at the state level so California
asked the California consumer privacy
act so it's important that it's in
California because obviously this is the
home based of most of the industry and
it moves the United States more toward
the gdpr it's not as strong as the GDP
are but it moves the needle in that
direction so already now if there's
gonna be a national Privacy Act it's
gonna have to supersede the state law
and that's a fundamental sort of
challenge to American politics that you
know whenever you override the states
you have a particular political debate
and so so that's that's basically the
industry is terrified of all the states
passing their own privacy laws so then
they have to do with a patchwork of
regulations oh yeah the industry wants a
national law badly and so now they're
basically gonna have to figure out how
to negotiate the Lavi industry lobbyists
are gonna have to negotiate what
concessions are they gonna give in order
to supersede the state laws and there
are other states have laws in the works
so New York has a really strong privacy
bill on the floor which is even stronger
than California's and so the minute you
get like New York and California passing
laws which have huge economic power in
the country California is the fifth
largest economy in the world that that's
gonna be this muscular force it's gonna
should have run the debate in Washington
DC and so I'm hopeful for that and it's
sort of where the kind of Federalist
dynamic of American politics will come
into play is that state voters will be
able to influence the debate by passing
laws at the Statehouse which then raises
the bar for Washington DC to override
those laws because people are gonna be
mad if Washington DC makes a weaker law
than their own state law so the the
advice that I would give to Americans
listening is actually go to your state
representatives first and engage with
them and put
push things along in your Statehouse and
that's gonna have a stronger impact on
what's going on in Washington DC in the
big picture that's interesting I think
the sad thing or the scary thing is that
in 2020 if it's unlikely that all of
this is going to have been washed
through by the time that we get there
yes someone may have lost a couple of
bullets of ammunition from their weapon
with regards to the fact that had
cambridge analytical I mean let's think
about this is a different iteration of
the world where the Cambridge analytical
scandal hadn't come out and they've got
another four years of voter data and
they've got another four years of
understanding behavioral change oh my
god you're just totally at the mercy but
as you say it's likely that these
tactics are going to be used again and
realistically because of the way that
they're done there's the presentation in
the documentary like the reporter from
The Guardian being targeted with what
was actually a really funny like very
degrading but very funny meme video all
of these sort of tactics that really
understand what gets people engaged and
what gets people going we are at the
mercy of our biases were just you know
how this Apes as as we often get called
and inoculating ourselves from this sort
of information is going to be incredibly
difficult I guess I mean are there any
apart from not using social media
are there any tactics that people can
use to help themselves with regards to
that other than a critical eye I
actually wouldn't even say don't use
social media because as i used i use it
in the film twitter was an important
weapon in my battle so social media can
be used for good and it should be and so
i actually don't think that people
should delete their cat counts it
doesn't really solve the problem so i
think the key is to try to use these
forces for good and for democracy and
not for an anti democracy as
you can especially until we figure out
how to better protect ourselves so yeah
I think it's mostly awareness and it's
the right kind of skepticism and to
better understand like how these
machines are manipulating us like one of
the things I like about the movie is the
way that it integrates the interface of
social media into the movie yeah it's
cool so that so that you realize that
the manipulation is right there in front
of you the sort of slot machine user
interfaces are the first layer of
manipulation and to think that you know
it's these like you know guys who are
hacking our minds with society
even before you get there it's just the
slot machine of these buttons and the
way that it's affecting the
neurotransmitters in our brains you know
we have to start there and think about
you know how these machines are and the
fact that Instagram has removed likes is
starting to test that out his strong
evidence that this realization that the
manipulation happens right on the
surface of these apps and interfaces I
think is a really important moment to
question not just you know the boogie
man of Cambridge analytic abut the whole
way we are spending most of our time in
scrolling missed him right yes yes it's
a I promise that I didn't give David my
um my notes before that but that was my
finishing point the fact that we've done
on this podcast 18 months ago I did an
episode called a hacker in your pocket
which is after I heard the first Tristan
Harris on Sam Harris podcast which is
what it exposed me and a lot of the
listeners to time well-spent and the
Center for Humane Technology and all
that sort stuff
Tristan's also now released his own
podcast which is fantastic you totally
right
on the surface I was thinking like this
is so terrible my reptile brains being
manipulated with red buttons and we've
got we've got entire posts that are a
rundown of how to change your
notification settings on
phone so that you don't get triggered as
much in you know we're playing we're
playing up here thinking that we're
pulling weeds out where is where on top
of an atomic bomb that's below it and
we're actually just like making no
difference at all like forget the fact
that your phone wants you to be on your
phone a fair bit and your attention
spans gone down like your entire
worldview is being manipulated it's so
vast yeah yep it is it is it is and you
know I until you learn how the sausage
is made it's hard to appreciate it it's
you know yeah I agree
um so David I really appreciate your
time for coming on if people want to
find out more first off go watch the
great hack on Netflix after that any
blogs that you would recommend or where
can people get in touch with yourself or
find out more sure so as its depicted in
the movie I'm very active on Twitter and
it's so you can follow me on prof
Carroll and happy to engage with people
there and I think that's a good starting
point I tend to post a lot of what I'm
looking at and so I think it's a good
jumping-off point you won't find me on
Facebook anymore but but if you want to
reach out direct to me you know jot you
can slide into my DMS and I can give you
my email address fantastic David I
really do wish you luck with the rest of
this campaign I'm going to be watching
with a lot of interest I say I'm sure
that the listeners will be will be super
excited to go down the rabbit holes that
your Twitter provides and yeah we'll see
you know maybe in in a year's time or
something like that we'll be able to do
a a catch-up episode and we'll be able
to see where the state of the of the
2020 year has taken us and stuff like
that but for now I thank you so much and
be on the lookout for a twist in the in
in in the fall
- the way the movie ends there's going
to be a twist ending in a couple of
months so be on the lookout for that
leave us with that open well on that
note ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much for tuning in professor Carol we'll
catch you later on thanks so much for
having me on Chris
[Music]
you